[Music]
you're all up late last night watching
the Democratic convention right that
would be about 1/8 of you I think that's
a quick poll I just took yeah everyone
else is running around naked right why
would someone do that I don't know at
the the Democratic National Convention
began last night last night two of these
speakers at the Democratic convention
were identical twin brothers Joaquin and
Julian Castro identical twins did you
see them yeah apparently promising
identical twins was the only way to get
Bill Clinton to show up man was he
disappointed they're dudes
[Laughter]
today the Democrats added the word God
to their official party platform yeah
yeah it's in the part that reads did you
see Michelle Obama's biceps oh my god
did you see those guns on she could beat
the crap out of me in like two seconds
which is really saying something was I'm
so tough
I thought does she did a good job though
she gave a great speech last night
Michelle Obama said the first car
Barack picked her up in was so old you
could see the ground below them yeah and
then today Ann Romney said the same
thing about MIT's first helicopter she
give away some nice details about their
family life in her speech last night
first lady Michelle Obama said her
husband has dinner with his girls where
they strategize about middle school
relationships
yeah which explains why today the
Pentagon ordered a drone strike on that
lying [ __ ] Ashley
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey it's been reported that one of these
surprise speakers at the Democratic
convention is going to be Scarlett
Johansson you believe that yeah just
gonna speak yeah for her speech she'll
be talking to an empty chair and telling
it hey my eyes are up here okay i perv
interesting fun fact at this year's
Democratic convention 8 percent of the
delegates are gay a historic record
eight percent this will be the first
time a presidential candidate will be
nominated by a show of jazz hands
[Applause]
won't it there's there's other news
other news besides the DNC NASA you've
heard about this they're having a
contest to let kids come up with the
name for a newly discovered asteroid
near the earth they find an asteroid
they're gonna let kids name it well the
kids have decided and Earth's greatest
astronomers are now studying asteroid
buttmunch or Bieber fart
shouldn't let kids handle that one
baskin-robbins introduced a new ice
cream flavor called ice cream nachos
yeah in case you're wondering they came
up with the idea yesterday at 4:20
of course the biggest news of all we can
talk about the planet we can talk about
the DNC but Snooki is a new mom that's
really the most important news new mom
Snooki said that thanks to her baby she
is done partying yeah she said the
toughest thing to get used to now is
that now when she whips her breasts out
at 3:00 a.m. it's not because a DJ told
her to Houstons and some mothers and if
your mother speaking of breasts it was
my favorite transition of all time some
mothers did you read this our turning to
Facebook to buy breast milk for their
babies yes they're getting it on
Facebook now call me old-fashioned why
can't they just get breast milk we're
nature intended them to get it
Craigslist that's when you get breast
milk
[Applause]
[Music]
you